Artificial intelligence program developed from needs
Cold War White and Mikio want to prove that they are bad for Megaronya and write in an advantageous
way What kind of hand are you using to prove that your gear is better than anything
else?  Hey, I guess
the reason I didn't go up to Jorling was
related to the gear of Shirotsuchi. I told you everything I knew.
What's more natural? The
ceremony isn't time anymore.  If I can pull it out again, I
'll leave
it for ging, but I wonder if
that's the case. No, what I like is that artificial feed has no weaknesses.
You already know that it responds perfectly to the gear movement of the other party detected by the sensor with automatic control.
How do you do that? Dee
What was wrong with
you now?
It's the gear that senses it.
The sensor of the weak electromagnetic wave of the opponent's gear is
quite the one that the
production of frozen soil is completely cured.
Miki Ono Ace ca
n't react diagonally.  I didn't want to fight
Gearless transfer
I didn't think about this, but I can do this The old
man said that tonight's ceremony can be the center
Teppei